- [Kelly Clarkson] Alright
let's finish this up
with one more single parent story
proving that you can
be a strong role model
for your kids all on your own.
This is what I am liking.
(upbeat music)
A mom in New Jersey
recently took the TikTok
to share her approach with her
19 month old daughter Luna,
when it comes to explaining
why Luna has one mommy
and no daddy, take a look.
- [Mom] So the way I'm raising Luna-
She doesn't want to be in this video.
You going to say good morning?
(baby laughing)
Luna and I are a family
two. A mom and a daughter.
She wants to play with the video stand.
Some families have one parent,
some families have two parents.
A parent can be a mom like Luna and I.
Mom, baby. Family of two.
Some families are a mom and a mom.
Some families are two dads.
Some families might be a mom and a dad.
You might have a mom and a bonus dad.
Family dynamics in 2021
going onto 2022 almost
needs to be taught to our
children at the young age.
So as they grow up, it's more normalized.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Amen.
(crowd cheering)
The video instantly got
tens of thousands of views
and hundreds of parents praising her
for her honesty and awareness.
We have this proud single mama on the line
watching on NBC for New York at two.
What's up Cassie?
(crowd cheering)
Hello. Well, first of all,
I grew up in a small town.
I just have to tell you.
And literally only knew of one other kid
that had divorced parents.
That there was a different
kind of family scenario going on.
It didn't really happen a lot
in this small town I'm from.
So, you do feel like you're an odd ball,
like as a kid and like
the daddy daughter dances,
like all that kind of stuff comes up.
And I think it's so cool what
you're doing and teaching
at a very young age that
like, there is no norm,
like everything is a
norm. It's just your norm.
So thank you for doing this.
(crowd cheering)
Is that kind of why you made the video
just to ensure that like, she
feels like protected safe,
and this is her norm like growing up?
- [Mom] Absolutely. I mean,
single parents are just such
a normal aspect in everyday
life for so many families
of so many different communities.
And it's just so important to
get the message out there that
just because you're a single parent
and just because that word single
is in front of your parenthood story,
doesn't make you any less of a parent.
And my daughter and I being
a family of two, together,
we are absolutely everything
and single parents can do
absolutely anything and
everything that we want to do.
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Absolutely
- [Mom] So that is my biggest one.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I love it.
So thank you, Cassie.
I'm liking your posts right now, right?
Oh my God, adorable.
She's so adorable.
Well, that's not all our
season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly
Clarkson show wants to honor
ultimate overachievers
just like you ma'am.
So they're going to be
using their G2 gelling pen
to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How does that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- [Mom] Oh, what?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah
Nice to talk to you girl.